[Music]
all right today the first lady melania
trump traveled
to two military bases in a navy aircraft
carrier to meet our troops
thanked them for their service this
holiday season today during her tour of
the uss george h.w
bush well i had the chance to sit down
with the first lady and why this is
important
because while we're enjoying christmas
many of them won't be with their
families take a listen
madam first lady thank you so much for
doing this so you said
before you came here and i watched you
with all these troops today
he said that this is about our troops
our families who sacrifice
daily for our freedoms our hearts our
prayers or
with all of our deployed soldiers
sailors airmen marines who will not be
home for christmas
and so you decided to do this trip tell
me more about that
well i wanted to come and visit military
families and also the service men and
women
it's very important that we support them
holidays are coming not many of them
they will be with their families
so for me it's very important to show
them that the president and i and the
country
where we are behind them you know what's
amazing so we're on the
uss george h.w bush who recently passed
away
they put as many as 5 000 people on this
ship
i was watching you as you were watching
the plane the jets come in and out
if we tipped it over it would be the
size of the empire state building
what do you think when you see this it's
incredible even when i
flew over here you see the ship it's
very small and then you're approaching
and it's
it's really big and it was great to meet
some of the
some of them some of the who serve here
now today there are 3 000 service men
and women on it right right now
and i saw the airplanes taking off and
landing and it's incredible what they do
the cost of freedom is high very high we
forget sometimes don't we correct yeah
i watched you as you worked the rope
line as you spoke with
the families it seemed to me that they
they cling to you and they want to send
you messages what are they saying to you
just they're thanking me for the service
that what i do for them
and i thank them for the service
i guess i see that we have a incredible
support out there
and they see what i'm doing and that i'm
here for them
and to support them yeah let me ask so
i would say i told a lot of people i was
going to be interviewing you
there is a curiosity about you i don't
know how you take that but
i think a lot of people know your
husband is so outspoken
and you've been behind the scenes but
you're making it out more you went on
your trip
you went to what nigeria ghana malawi
yes i went to the four countries i
started with ghana
and malawi kenya and egypt i did a
five day trip in africa on
all those four countries it was an
amazing trip
and they were very happy i came there
and i worked with the usaid
so we are helping them to become
self-reliant yeah i noticed in
interviews one of the things you
often say that you took first you
defined yourself in the abc interview i
thought it was a really interesting
question
as a mom a wife
as the first lady of the united states
as a friend
and then you talked about that you're
confident
you're very focused and you use the term
stay true to myself you use that term a
lot
i want you to expand on that what does
that mean considering and i'll ask you
about your roots a little bit but that
stuck out to me i i do what they think
it's right
i know i will get the criticism
from the public or from the media
but i will do what is right and what i
feel it's right
for the country and for the people
and that's what i say i want to stay
true to myself and listen myself
and what to do and what is right what is
wrong
and live meaningful life every day you
you talked about that this is temporary
you see it as temporary
would you want to stay for a second term
i think my husband
he's doing an incredible job the country
does
best ever so yes
i i think i wanted the country continue
to do well
you come from a small town in slovenia
and i don't think you've talked a lot
publicly
about your journey from that small town
to paris to all these major cities
from there to new york city tell us
about that journey was it
were your parents with you were you a
model and alone
after my studies i went and to the
modeling business
and i lived in milan and paris and in
1996 i moved to new york
and then my career
i loved it and
i stayed in new york and here we are
today
you it's interesting because you're now
traveling but you end up in the biggest
city
and you've told the story about how you
met the president
um when did you know that he was the one
did was there a moment we had a great
chemistry when we met
in 1998 and
we we started dating and
you know we dated for a long time before
we got married and
we got married we had the sun but we had
a
great chemistry from the day one yeah
did you
is there a moment that you realized wow
small town slovenia now i'm the first
lady of the united states and i'm living
in the white house
was there a moment that you realize this
is real it's incredible especially
when you think about it your life where
you were born
and all the steps you took i took a lot
of steps it's not just like you end up
here
you learn a lot on the way here and
in my business in fashion business it's
uh it's a tough business as well
and uh here the politics is as well it's
a tough business
and you need to have very thick skin
yeah what's been the hardest
for you since you've become first lady
what's been the hardest thing that you
have to deal with
i would say the opportunists who are
using my name
or my family name to advance themselves
from comedians to
journalists to performers
book writers does it hurt it doesn't
hurt
the problem is they writing the history
and it's not correct and
especially when there's speculation
about you and your family and your
marriage
and you address that in past interviews
yes i did and you know some
they like to focus on the gossip and
i would like to they focus on the
substance and
what we do not just about uh
nonsense what was it you said when
if he ran you know you knew he would win
i told him you know if you run because i
i knew him i knew
how he connects with the people he built
incredible business and his mind is
into the business and to make america
great
and successful so i saw how he connects
with the people so that's why i said
like you know if you run you
you will win and it's possibility i know
people want to know this
do you often weigh in on the issues of
the day
with the president i know you you do
watch a lot of news
you're very aware of what's going on
what do you think in terms of
what can you insight could you give us
maybe a better way to ask it
as to how when you feel strongly about
something
that you would relay that to him i wish
to have
to a time to watch more news but i don't
watch them
very busy with my office and traveling
and doing my work yes i watch you
and i sometimes also tape the shows
and have if i have a time i watch it but
i know exactly what's going on i follow
what's going on
and i give my husband advice and my
honest opinion
and sometimes he listens and sometimes
he doesn't if i look at the two of you
and i know the two of you pretty well
i've known him for a very long time
um i don't think they could be two
different styles
he fights he's combative you've
discussed the issues
of tweeting and social media and you've
even said you've asked him to tone it
down a little bit
how does that go over well we could see
it
meaning it's not working okay i don't
agree with his stone sometimes and i
tell him that
so as i said before sometimes he listens
like he was going to say something and
you said i said i said to him you know
i don't think you need to uh tweet that
out but
on the end it's it's his decision he
knows the consequences
he's an adult and you know but he's a
fighter
he's the fighter you know it's
interesting is that you saw the exchange
i assume yesterday with him and
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi and i
gave my commentary on it i said
that's what america elected correct
somebody that fights hard for promises
correct um what do you what would you
want america to know about him behind
the scenes
that maybe they don't see or know
that maybe the media would never portray
about him
that he's fighting for the america and
american people
every day every day he wants to govern
the right way and sometimes it's tough
because he could see that media wants to
bash
and focus on negativity
we have an amazing part two of the
interview with our first lady that will
air tomorrow night